well speaking of the queen bee pre-sale
tickets for Beyonce's Renaissance tour
go on sale today in fact Las Vegas is in
the first group of pre-sale cities so
the concert at Allegiant not until
August but our Candace Charles is there
right now because it's a lot of Buzz
about these tickets and whether it's
even going to work Candace
absolutely good morning to you good
morning folks it's been an exciting
couple of weeks of people I've been
waiting and talking about this that was
announced on the first day of Black
History Month that Beyonce will be
coming back to tour her seventh studio
album that's the first tour in about
four years and she has stopped really
all over the world from May to September
but as we mentioned folks are concerned
that they'll even be able to get hands
on those tickets after the situation
with Taylor Swift and Ticketmaster now
take the master preparing it's divided
registration to three groups of cities
each has its own deadline to register
for pre-sale now the registration
deadline for Vegas was last Thursday if
you want to attend the North American
League of the tour you must be
registered as a verified fan but that
doesn't guarantee you'll get a ticket
for every one ticket there are about
eight people who want one that's
according to Ticketmaster so
Ticketmaster has a lottery system to
determine who gets an access code for
the sale and it was put on the wait list
try directly with Ticketmaster and try
to be on the on sale time when you can
get there you know get their half hour
early and you know log in and get into a
waiting room and
you know hope to get lucky
yeah that's some great advice there from
Tony Baptist from the Las Vegas
tickets.com he says make sure you know
your budget so you know what to look for
and quickly can snag those tickets now
if you do go the resell right or else he
does advise that you make sure you look
for a verified site you can check with
the Nevada ticket broker Association
again those tickets go on sale today at
1pm for the big concert that's going to
be happening here August 26th of course
stick with us for the latest right here
on airline adult show but for now I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now